well another day another journey hey
everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we will be taking a look at
blogolati's new controversial 90-day
muscle gain journey but first let me
tell you about my sponsor billbar so you
guys know i love filming time because it
also means snack time and i love that i
get to take you guys along with me for a
little
snacky snack so you guys know i love
these bars because they're really unlike
any other protein bar that i've tried
because they actually
taste like a candy bar no chalky powdery
mealy texture just chocolatey goodness
with a side of protein so today's flavor
let's go
mint
mint brownie oh
yeah
17 grams of protein specifically
let's get in there
[Music]
she good and you guys all know what i
say about the zero guilt thing unless
you stole it from a baby all foods are
zero guilt now these guys are one of my
favorite go-to bedtime snacks or i use
them on top of oatmeal to really bump up
the satiety factor and make a hunger
crushing combo so if you guys want to
give these a try
check out the link in my description and
use my promo code abbiesharp15 to get 15
off your order and you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey and if you are new here
hello don't forget to subscribe to this
channel hit that bell and follow me on
tick tock and instagram at abby's
kitchen okay so
to recap my last review of blog a
lotties aka cassie ho so cassie has a
history of disordered eating and body
dysmorphia after competing in the
fitness modeling world she dealt with a
lot of super gross criticism as she
gained weight post competition life and
she went viral for her commentary on the
pressures of the industry she then
embarked on a 90-day journey to get in
the best shape of her life and in the
process she lost 20 pounds or what she
called the excess weight off her body
and the toxicity out of her life now i
already shared my thoughts on said
journey in my video right here but a few
weeks ago
cassie popped back up on my discovery
page with her new 90 day journey this
time as her instagram post suggested it
wasn't about weight loss it was about
muscle growth now before we get into our
plan i wanted to just remind everyone
that i respect body autonomy if you want
to lose weight i support you if you want
to gain muscle i support you neither
goal is morally right or wrong it's just
your journey so you know you do you it
is always an adventure and from reading
her blog it does seem like cassie
actually expected to get some pushback
as she did in round one but she didn't
care because she was doing this journey
for herself and i think that ultimately
that's how it should be but i also want
folks at home to think critically about
the wellness trends that they see here
on social media these days intentional
weight loss is somewhat taboo but
dieting for the sake of muscle gain is
often seen as admirable and celebrated
and this is just a cultural observation
this is not a judgment from me of cassie
and i do think that there are obvious
health benefits to getting stronger and
building muscle but i bring it up to
remind folks that just because gaining
muscle is seen as more morally neutral
in wellness culture it still does
require dieting you know it still is
body manipulation and while there's
nothing wrong with that it can be
triggering for some folks so if i were
on cassie's coaching team which i am not
so of course my commentary today is
general and not specifically for her i
would be asking a lot of questions about
her disordered eating history before
starting a journey like this oh my god
more than 20 questions i was oh my god
sports dietitian rebecca kirk mcconville
told me that being proactive with your
nutrition and flexible with variety and
timing and honoring your hunger on days
that it's greater than usual by allowing
yourself to eat more than what was
planned are all good green flags to look
for before starting a fitness diet it's
also important that you have a team in
place that can identify signs of
disordered eating so for example rebecca
mentioned that if the previous eating
disorder was more compulsive in nature
your coach will need to make sure that
you're not doing more activity or eating
less than what's in your plan so always
have a team in place to keep an extra
eye so with that said let's take a look
at cassie's proposed protocol and how
likely it is to result in substantial
muscle gain albert einstein said it best
when you look big you get big simple
math first of all
it's important to note that gaining
muscle mass is really no easy feat for
an already lean woman remember when
you're in high school and afraid to lift
weight because you didn't want to bulk
up yeah
it doesn't happen like that
it takes a hell of a lot of work and
generally speaking a lot of time as well
but basically a woman's ability to put
on muscle mass depends on a few
important things genetics which is
somewhat out of our control a diet that
has enough protein and calories and fat
and carbs a training protocol with a
high enough stimulus threshold adequate
rest which means days off of exercise as
well as actual sleep and other factors
like inflammation and hormones cassie's
starting her journey with an already
very lean physique at 25.6 body fat
which puts her in the 20th percentile
for women's body fat now adding muscle
is admittedly quite a challenge for lean
folks especially if hormones are
resultantly out of whack now i don't
know what cassie's estrogen levels are
as she only shared her progesterone
levels in the blog post which she
mentioned were currently low but
estrogen is actually important for
muscle growth with research suggesting
somewhere in the world of 24 to 30 body
fat as the sweet spot for healthy levels
so i'm just gonna operate with the
assumption that her estrogen levels are
okay but considering her other life goal
is to get pregnant and that her
progesterone levels are already low i do
worry about the hormonal tax of a recomp
like this i spoke to my colleague sports
dietitian chelsea cross who suggested
that in situations like this she would
encourage starting with like a health
phase where the focus would be on
optimizing hormones before trying to
manipulate macros to build muscle if our
hormones are not at an optimal place our
body is going to resist growth and i'm
going to discuss this in a little bit
more detail shortly but let's start by
talking about cassie's proposed diet in
general so cassie's sample meal plan in
her kickoff blog post has just over 1500
calories with 41 protein 19 fat and 43
carbs that puts her at 1.25 grams of
protein per pound of body weight which
is within the range of what we discussed
as optimal in my video here now i'm also
seeing her protein spread throughout the
day in five smallish meals first of all
i am definitely glad to see that we're
not trying to squeeze meals into like a
strict fasting regimen and that we're
spacing meals out throughout the day i'm
gonna be discussing this in a lot more
detail in an upcoming video but in short
when we're talking about women who are
dieting or engaging in a lot of exercise
we worry about what we call a state of
low energy availability and that's the
energy left for optimizing health after
you account for calories consumed and
exercise what we know is that for women
more hours a day spent with an energy
availability below 300 calories is
associated with menstrual dysfunction
and hormonal irregularities which as
we've established is not ideal for
muscle growth either so this is why it's
better to have a more even intake of
calories throughout the day rather than
to try to cram your meals into like a
short intermittent fasting feeding
window can we stop and eat the other
reason why we're loving the mini meal
approach is that it allows for optimal
use of that protein for muscle protein
synthesis so research suggests that
muscle protein synthesis is 25 greater
when the protein is distributed evenly
across meals versus trying to load it
into one or two big meals the body can
really only utilize about 0.25 to 0.4
grams of protein per kilogram of body
weight for muscle protein synthesis
every three to four hours so this is why
most fitness competitors and
bodybuilders eat a number of meals every
single day now most of cassie's meals
have around 30 grams of protein but on
average based on this calculation she's
likely only able to utilize up to 23
grams per meal for muscle protein
synthesis so what she's doing is working
for her great it's not like the extra
protein is wasted because there are of
course satiety benefits and calorie
benefits to that extra protein per meal
i also don't think we need to be
obsessive and perfect about any of this
but i would say if she's finding that
the diet protocol isn't yielding results
she could try adding an extra meal and
ensuring those meals are better balanced
with the other two macros and that
brings me to talk about the fats again
we can see from her blog post that one
of her goals is to improve her
progesterone levels to eventually
conceive but because she only has 1500
calories to play with and 40 of those
calories are going towards protein we're
left with just 32 grams of fat now
research suggests that for optimal
hormonal health we want to aim for at
least 0.8 to 1 gram of fat per kilogram
of body weight so that would mean
44 to 57 grams of fat per day and
remember optimal hormones are not only
important for conception but also for
building muscle and then of course
there's the carbs this plant is
relatively low carb for your average joe
never mind someone looking to actively
build muscle so carbs are not only
important for cardio and replenishing
glycogen stores post-workout but they
also elicit an insulin response that
helps to drive protein into the muscle
faster to support muscle growth so it's
really strange to me that she would
almost purposefully be choosing ultra
low carb meals here like we have a
zucchini mug cake for meal 3 with monk
fruit as the only sweetener sauteed
zucchini noodles for meal 4 with just
veggies and chicken and then protein
pancakes made of just protein powder and
egg whites with a little strawberries on
top for meal 5. so risa suggests that we
want to aim for between 4 to 6 grams of
carbs per kilogram of body weight for
muscle growth which would work out to
between 228 and 342 grams of carbs in
other words her 164 grams of carbs
seem
grossly inadequate on this plan it's
also generally accepted that we want a
one to three ratio of protein to carbs
in the post-workout meal and while i'm
not really sure where in the day she's
training i will say that
none of her meals are
optimized with training in mind in most
cases we see like a one gram of carb to
one gram of protein ratio sometimes
slightly less and sometimes slightly
more but definitely not the optimal
amount of carbs for post-workout
anywhere in the day now obviously in
real life we would never tell a client
who's used to eating low carb to
suddenly triple their carbs this this
would happen gradually over time but i
do think it's safe to say that she has a
ways to go considering her goals finally
let's talk about the most obvious one
the calories i'm not sure what cassie
was eating at maintenance before this
journey but on her last 90 day journey
when the goal is to lose fat she was
apparently eating around 1200 calories
not good my friends now i'm not gonna
get into why that's problematic because
i already did that right here but that
likely means 1500 calories at least is
being used as a maintenance calorie
level and i don't know 500 calories
actually seems pretty low for
maintenance considering her activity
level even outside of this journey never
mind a goal to gain muscle so i do
wonder if there was maybe some severe
metabolic damage from her bikini model
days when she was apparently consuming a
thousand calories a day that maybe she
hasn't taken the time to properly
reverse diet out of regardless of where
or how things have netted out chelsea
and i agree that you know it's very
difficult to actively build muscle
without some amount of a caloric surplus
and if 1500 calories is her surplus well
it's not the journey that i would be
investing in at the moment so if we were
to look to add just the minimum amount
of carbs and fats that we just discussed
we would be looking at closer to
1925 calories which still actually seems
quite modest to me but it's a far more
appropriate starting place for sure now
i'm admittedly filming this well in
advance so i'm really not sure how
things have netted out at this point but
in her january 30th blog post and her
february first blog post she discusses
slightly upping her fats and calories so
i am glad to see her tweaking her diet
based on how her body responds and feels
each week i expect she's also going to
need to up her carbs a lot more as well
which i know may be a more psychological
challenge for her given her diet history
and also maybe what she's become
accustomed to much of cassie's instagram
feed has featured low or lower carb
meals she also kicked off her last 90
day journey doing legit keto and i
suspect that in her fitness competition
days she cut carbs pretty low too so i
get that old habits die hard
it's often so deeply ingrained in a lot
of our heads that protein is for muscle
and carbs promote fat gain but that is
scientifically untrue so next i want to
briefly touch on her training regimen
noting that i'm not a personal trainer
so this is out of my scope to speak to
the specifics but i did ask my colleague
chelsea if training six days for muscle
growth with a pseudo rest day in there
aka a low impact cardio day would
support her muscle growth goals and in
short her answer was
no according to chelsea if you're able
to train basically every day you're very
likely not hitting a great enough
stimulus threshold to elicit muscle
growth at least not at a very noticeable
pace and i noticed in one of her blog
entries that she noted that by day six
she was so exhausted that she had to
take a day off early which is exactly
what i would expect i know it can be a
bit of a mind for someone who's used to
training for a lean body to shift to the
goal of training for muscle growth but
it does take a very different approach
finally let's talk about the importance
of sleep for muscle growth not only are
actual rest days off of working out
important for muscle growth but so is
quality sleep so you probably heard
about rem and non-rem sleep both of
which are very important for health but
it's this non-rem sleep cycle that is
particularly important for muscle growth
when you enter into non-rem sleep phase
your pituitary gland releases growth
hormone to stimulate tissue growth and
muscle repair and the research
definitely supports this so one study
divided participants into sleeping five
and a half hours or eight and a half
hours and put them both on a calorie
deficit for two weeks while the total
weight loss was the same the better
sleepers preserved sixty percent more
muscle and the poor sleepers lost 60
more muscle another study found that
after just one night of no sleep
participants muscles showed signs of
increased protein breakdown and their
fat tissue showed elevated levels of
metabolites involved in fat storage we
also know that under eating over
exercising and not getting enough
physical sleep are all considered
stressors on the body and stressors
throw up hormones like cortisol which
have an overall catabolic effect not to
mention being tired obviously affects
workout performance so it's really not
surprising that
sleep can compromise your gains so i
absolutely agree that focusing on sleep
will be imperative to her goals both in
the gym and for normalizing her hormones
in preparation to conceive so with all
that said do i think cassie's 90 day
journey to gain muscle is a realistic
goal well i didn't see a specific
numerical goal so i'm not really sure
what she's expecting to see in 90 days
but i don't think i would expect to see
significant muscle growth in this short
period of time i don't think this is
enough calories i don't think it's
enough carbs or fats for hormonal
regulation and i don't think it's enough
rest period if we were a total trading
newbie jumping into a protocol like this
sure we would probably see significant
progress but cassie is already well
conditioned very lean and her protocol
hasn't left much of a buffer for growth
so i would suggest either adjusting
expectations or going back to the
drawing board with the plan and there's
no shame in either outcome i remind you
this is a journey and while i think
putting an arbitrary timeline on these
things does tend to set us up for
disappointment the process is often just
as important as the end result and i
hope that she does get to learn a lot
about this process that she's willing to
share so on that note that's all that i
have for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on what or who
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]